CAROLINE: My name
is Caroline and I'm
delighted to introduce you to
today's speaker, Danny Fields,
in conversation with
Fionnuala Meehan.
Former manager of The
Ramones, Danny is a music icon
and is widely recognized as
a founding father of punk.
Fionnuala is a huge music
fan, I've been told,
and attends the punk rock
festival, Download, every year.
Their conversation will
last about 30 minutes
and it will be followed by an
audience Q&A, after which Danny
will be signing
copies of his book
for those of you who are
here in time to receive one,
just at the side of the stage.
I think we're in for
a pretty good treat,
so I'll hand you right over.
Thank you for coming.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Danny.
DANNY FIELDS: Hello.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
Welcome to Dublin.
Welcome to Ireland.
DANNY FIELDS: Thank you.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: And
welcome to the Google office.
This is our-- as I was
saying to you earlier--
this is our EMEA headquarters.
So not just Irish
people in the audience,
but people from all
over the region.
DANNY FIELDS: If I could
see them, I would know that.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yes.
Yeah.
DANNY FIELDS: [INAUDIBLE].
And if you're going like this,
I won't know, so feel free.
You can stick your
tongues out any time.
I cannot see you guys.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Don't worry.
We'll have plenty of
audience participation later.
So 50 years-- we
were just talking--
50 years in the music industry.
That's pretty amazing.
And in looking at your life
across things like journalism,
being an author,
promoter, manager--
DANNY FIELDS: I have to
scoff at all those words.
They're kind of [INAUDIBLE].
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: They
sound pretty impressive.
DANNY FIELDS: Yeah,
but we're trying
to redefine each
one of them in turn.
But, yes, you have
to have a word for--
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yes.
DANNY FIELDS: OK.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: And
so, you don't strike me
as a person who,
maybe, consciously made
a decision to do a certain
amount of time in each one.
So how did you end up having
such a fantastic career?
How did you make
the decision to move
between those different things?
DANNY FIELDS: Well, when
you have nothing to do,
you have to do something.
You know what?
I'm guided by what I love
to see and who's talented
and who's beautiful and who says
it great and shoots it great.
And is great.
That's it.
And sounds great, of
course-- number one.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Number one.
DANNY FIELDS: Or great
songs, number one.
And I was one of-- what
do you do with this kid?
He's like-- I graduated
from college when I was 19.
Didn't know-- do
something-- a career--
I didn't want to be a doctor
like my father, that's
for sure.
I was not a
business-- certainly,
for sure, and to this day.
I answered an ad
in the newspaper.
I got a job at a magazine
for teenage girls.
And [SLAP] I was in
the music business.
OK.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: That's
where it all started.
DANNY FIELDS: Yeah.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yeah.
It's pretty humbling to look
at all of the fantastic artists
that you've-- some discovered--
worked with over the years.
I mean, The Doors,
Velvet Underground,
The Ramones, The Stooges.
When you saw these bands
for the first time,
were you reacting-- was it just
instinct, where you were going,
yeah, I'm going to
bet on these ones.
These ones are going to be big.
How did you-- how did
you make those decisions?
DANNY FIELDS: When you love
something or someone-- for me,
the first band I loved
was The Velvet Underground
because they were kind
of our house band.
They were rehearsing
where we hung out.
We'd follow them on the road.
And their commercial
destiny was clearly zero.
There's nothing-- no place
you could go with that.
But we didn't-- you don't
care because you love it.
And love their songs.
"Heroin" was the national
anthem of my little unit--
not the drug.
The song.
You heard that and you were
defined for the time being
and you were placed.
And you just stay with them.
Love them.
Stay with them.
If they break up-- which they
did-- then stay with the ones
you loved who were
doing the songs, which
for me-- three
musicians from that band
were subsequently very important
to me, who are Lou Reed, John
Cale, and Nico.
And each of them became--
you get absorbed.
It's the story of life.
We can't see it from above.
We can only look at it now.
It's been 50 years, as
you say, and go, oh,
that's what happened.
Because when it's happening,
you don't know it's happening.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yeah.
And can I ask you, of
all of those artists,
maybe who some of
your favorites were?
Is that--
DANNY FIELDS: I
don't like favorites.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
--an unfair question?
DANNY FIELDS: I have
so many favorites.
Beethoven is a favorite.
But I don't want
to hear about him.
I don't know much about him.
All those bands were--
would've had careers.
The Ramones would
have been signed,
The Stooges-- in
spite of themselves--
would've been signed.
Nico is the artist I'm
proudest of having something
to do with because she was
thought of as a beauty, which
she hated.
As much as you can hate
being called a beauty.
I can't imagine that.
No one's ever called me that.
But she didn't like
being merely beautiful.
And she had been through
Brian Jones and Jimmy Page
in New York.
And her first solo album
was recording songs of her
boyfriends'-- Jackson
Browne and Lou Reed.
But she was writing the
most astonishing songs.
She was a songwriter and she
worshiped English language
poetry.
And she would hang
out in my apartment
and look at-- because in
college, I majored in poetry,
so I had a lot of complete
works of Chaucer and John Donne.
You all know what
that must look like.
And she said, oh, I want this
to be the name of my own album.
And it was a poem by Wordsworth.
And the phrase was
"The Marble Index."
And this referred to
a bust of Isaac Newton
in Cambridge that was in marble.
And had a line in
it-- of course,
it's not a familiar poem.
It's not a household
poem at all.
Contemplating a bust of
Isaac Newton in Cambridge.
And it referred to the
marble index-- marble,
as in a statue-- of
a mind-- and now I'm
going to get this not exactly
right-- traveling alone
through the universe,
which is Isaac Newton.
And of course, Nico-- and her
grandiosity and insanity--
identified with that.
And said, oh, the marble index.
I said, what?
Is that an album title?
OK.
Oh, it's Wordsworth.
Oh, OK, Nico.
Yeah, you can call it that.
So bringing her together with
the president of the record
company, she sat on the
floor with a harmonium.
[MIMICS HARMONIUM] And he said,
yes, we've got to sign her.
Get me John Cale on
the phone, quick.
And they did astonishing
collaboration, which was 1968.
It was 100 years
ahead of its time
and will be 100 years ahead
of its time in 2068, 2168.
That's how amazing
that album was.
I'm proudest of that.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
You're proudest of that.
DANNY FIELDS: OK.
Because there's this amazing
songwriter blossoming
and being recorded as that.
And the amazing
musicianship of John.
It was two people in
that studio and it
sounds like you have
the Berlin Symphony
Orchestra or something.
He did it all.
And I had a feeling that--
from the days of The Velvet
Underground, they were kind
of waiting to collaborate.
This was it.
And that was it.
And my favorite photographer did
the cover shot-- Guy Webster.
And great album.
That's it.
That's number one.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: OK.
DANNY FIELDS: Everything else--
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
That's fantastic.
DANNY FIELDS: --it
would've happened anyhow.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: OK.
DANNY FIELDS: Not to--
I didn't do anything.
That is the one thing I did.
I need some of this.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Let
me pour it for you.
I'll pour it for you.
DANNY FIELDS: Bear with me.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: There we go.
DANNY FIELDS: Yeah,
this was easy.
OK.
Ask a question while
I whet my whistle.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
I was just going
to say, while you're pouring
there, I'll ask a question.
So your book-- it's
a beautiful book.
DANNY FIELDS: It's a non-book.
All books are non-books now.
It's photographs.
It's a book of photographs
that I took of The Ramones
in the first two years I was
with them as their manager.
Because they were perfect
and they came to me
completely formed.
They were-- there was
nothing I could say.
Change your hair, or change your
shirt, or change your shoes,
or change the order
of your songs,
or-- ugh-- change the
bass-- untouchable.
Because they're perfect.
Because I would not have
liked them in the first place
if they had not been perfect.
But-- oh, and you're the manager
and there's nothing to do.
The hotel rooms are
booked, the gig is booked,
the money's collected.
All that's done.
Legal.
I just started taking
pictures of them
because I was with them.
And I had access to
them and I was learning
how to be a photographer.
Just by [CLICK].
And they're just beautiful.
They're beautiful pictures.
And the boys are dead and I
thought this should be a book.
They're just-- I'm
not going to tell you
they're beautiful photographs
it sounds so vain, doesn't it?
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
But-- no, but they are.
DANNY FIELDS: But they are.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
They are beautiful.
DANNY FIELDS: And
it's a limited edition
by a friend of mine
in Paris, Fabrice
who did a book on Genesis
P-Orridge and a book
on Marc Almond.
Has amazing taste
that goes all over.
And he said-- and his partner
Richie Franklin in London--
so they commute.
And they wanted to do a
book of those photographs.
And I thought, yeah, OK.
And now I'm a
photographer because--
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
Another one [INAUDIBLE]
DANNY FIELDS: It says so.
A book of photographs,
and that's what it is.
What I had to do-- a photograph
is worth a million words,
or a thousand words--
what's the cliche?
You still have something
to say about it, especially
if you were there.
And here we see Dee Dee
picks up a piece of shit
on the capitol of
the United States
and puts it on a
balcony and lines
it up with the Washington
Monument and stands back
and-- you're, OK, it's art.
Because Dee Dee
was a great artist.
And there, he's being a
was a great visual artist.
I don't mean to use
the-- it's not all that.
But who else would
have been there
to watch him do that
without going, ew!
What are you doing?
He was making art.
So there's that.
And then just posing--
learning how to be them.
And then alone in
the dressing room.
You just-- I could be there.
I could be this close to
them, wherein they were
being private, with a camera.
And it wasn't like
ambushing them.
But it was because
they knew I was there.
They were learning how to be
ambushed by a photographer, who
was me-- who was their manager.
So if any of the
pictures were terrible,
they would never be seen.
I would-- you know,
I'm the manager.
They know I'm not going to let a
terrible picture get out there.
And then part of
that part-- this
is learning how to be with
a photographer who's not
your manager and
you don't be caught
with a piece of spaghetti
hanging out of your mouth.
Learn-- when you see that
camera anywhere near you--
you are-- this is work.
OK.
And I thought that these
points had to be made.
This is work.
You're public.
You're famous.
You're entertainers--
always now.
Off stage, on stage.
And that's the book.
So it's a book of
photographs and I love it.
It's called "My
Ramones" because it's
the four Ramones I
knew at the beginning,
before Tommy, the
drummer, left and was
replaced by another drummer,
who's quite a good drummer.
But he's not my Tommy and
it was no longer my Ramones.
And then they fired me.
And then they went and
recorded the song "Danny Says,"
which everbody was playing--
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yes.
They were just saying
it's not about you.
DANNY FIELDS: OK.
The song was called
"Tommy Says," when
Tommy Ramone was telling
them, your next job
is in-- wherever it was.
And it's Joey lamenting
that he wishes he
could be with his girlfriend.
But Tommy-- and then
switched to Danny
because it sounded better--
says we've got to go to Idaho.
I never told them-- they
never even went to Idaho
when I was working with them.
But it's good.
It works.
It's Phil Spector.
It was supposed to be a hit.
And it should've been.
It's really a good song.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
It's a great song.
DANNY FIELDS: It's not about me.
I wasn't there.
I had been fired before
they went into the studio
to record it.
But still, it's like-- this is--
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: So you
can't believe everything
you read on the internet.
DANNY FIELDS: It becomes
part of your life
because people say it is.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: I know.
Absolutely.
The book is beautiful.
The photographs are amazing.
DANNY FIELDS: Thank you.
Thank you.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: They are.
DANNY FIELDS: I
love to hear that.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
And the commentary
on New York, as well.
You're a New Yorker.
You were born in Queens, was it?
DANNY FIELDS: Yeah.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
And so if anybody--
I suppose if you're
interested in New York
and interested in The Ramones,
it's a fantastic book.
And I learned what
CBGB stand for.
I never knew what
CBGB stood for.
So that's one to look out for.
DANNY FIELDS: OK.
Well, that will serve you well.
It was really the first two
years of their existence.
And that's when I
was there and that's
when I was taking pictures.
And then-- pshhh.
But that's the record of--
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yeah.
It is a fantastic
record of what happened.
And we were talking earlier
about if that was today,
would bands-- similar bands--
be Snapchatting and constantly
streaming what's going on?
What's your view of--
because you, clearly,
wanted to record what
was going on then.
You were there taking pictures.
What's your view on
things like YouTube
and Snapchat and Facebook?
What's your view on them?
DANNY FIELDS: Facebook was
a nightmare for a few days.
And I said, get
this out of my life.
This is horrible.
I don't like what it does.
And my friends are going to
be people I know and like
and want to hug, and
be with, and talk to.
And what I say to my friends I
could not say to anyone else.
That's what the
definition of a friend
is-- you can communicate
with-- so I'm not going public
with my-- what's in my heart.
That required that
disconnect-- which, I can't.
It's still there.
I still get alerts from them.
And then someone
else put me on there.
There's some tombstone
with my name.
So if you write to them
and say something about me,
it's going to be there.
But just-- no.
I have-- no.
I have enough wonderful friends
who I love-- whom I love--
and I don't want to pick
them out of the crowd.
Another-- Snapchat?
I don't even know what it does.
YouTube is my life, and Google.
Those two are my life
because there's the universe.
And any song you
ever want is there.
It's on YouTube.
That's-- what more do you need
in life but YouTube to hear it
and Google to find
out what happened?
[LAUGHTER]
And the rest is bullshit.
It's a bunch of commentary.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't want to see 600 pictures
of me and my girlfriend.
And we went to ride a pony.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
There's no-- there's
no editing there.
Indulge-- if you
indulge 46-year-olds,
what are they going
to come up with?
Well, not much better than
what you can see anywhere,
except by accident.
Every once in a
while, there's going
to be something--
oh, this is great.
But I don't care.
Take it away-- Snapchat.
Don't take away my
YouTube or my Google.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
We will not do that.
DANNY FIELDS: Facebook
and-- it's a menace.
It only causes trouble.
The only-- people I love and
respect-- I can't name names.
A wonderful woman, who's
a very, very old, dear
friend, who's a great
international performer
and brilliant.
And she is on Facebook and
she will be sitting in Berlin
in an apartment with her
and she'll say, look, look,
they love what I
had for breakfast.
What?
They love what you
had for breakfast?
You're you.
You're an artist, you're a
performer, you're amazing.
They love what you
had for-- and you
see the need for approval coming
through this Facebook bullshit.
I hate that.
This is, like, whoa.
I love you.
I don't care what you
had for breakfast.
I'll always love you.
I've seen you want to
stage, get naked, or talk
about what's corrupt and
what's evil and what's good.
I don't want to know what
you had for breakfast.
And I certainly don't know why
you want 120,000 million people
to know what you
had for breakfast.
Or you care that they like what
you had-- how can they like
what you had for breakfast?
That was your egg.
It was not their--
[LAUGHTER]
This is all so-- I'm
too old for this world.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: I
wouldn't say this.
DANNY FIELDS: I got to get off
this bus pretty soon anyhow.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: No,
I wouldn't say that.
On a more personal note, as
we're on personal matters now,
what was it like-- or tell
me about coming out-- well,
I said this to you
earlier about coming out.
And you said, well, I
didn't really come out.
But can you talk a
little bit about that?
Because that-- still,
today, is still
difficult for some people.
DANNY FIELDS: I know.
I don't-- I was born out.
I don't know what
that means-- come out.
But I'm from New York.
And all my friends--
I just never--
and I went to school
at Penn and at Harvard
and there was no such
thing as coming out.
You didn't have to
say, Mom-- well,
what-- Mom found a letter.
OK.
You know, this happens.
And then, yeah.
I mean, it's all-- can't
be a surprise, Mom.
It's what you always
feared, expected, dreaded.
Yeah.
Let's move on.
So I-- saying that and being
dismissive about it makes
me think, well, there's someone
there in the middle of nowhere
who is ashamed,
concerned, depressed,
confused about his
or her sexuality.
Which now, has got-- you've
got 15 niches of that.
I can't follow
this LGG-- there's
another letter-- every
week, there's a new letter.
So I just call it BLT. And
everyone knows what that means.
And it sort of has
everything in it.
I can't follow this jewel--
if you're less talented, ugh!
This niche.
I don't know.
I know, I'm sounding
cynical here.
My heart is with anyone who
feels that they are not--
don't deserve to be a
human being because of whom
they love.
And what bodies
they want to hold.
And what they want to touch.
All that.
Who made those rules?
Nobody.
We don't need to reproduce.
Because that's
where we came from.
And we're living with a very
unfortunate set of biblical--
some people wandering through
a desert, saying, do this.
Don't do that.
Not me.
Not modern.
But I can't do any good by
saying these things, can I?
I just sound like, oh,
you'll be all right.
Look at me.
I'm fine.
I, famously-- I read in
a "Village Voice" story
that I was famously gay.
Famously gay, what
does that mean?
[LAUGHTER]
It was about a
Bette Midler show.
Even people who
are famously gay,
like me, hugged and
kissed her after the show.
What does famously gay-- how
can you-- what does that mean?
But that's what it means.
And do what you want and I
will, hopefully, do what I want.
Which is, right now,
have some water.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
Have some water.
DANNY FIELDS: Because that
was hard going through that.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yeah.
That was-- no, thank you for--
DANNY FIELDS: It's
not a Facebook--
it's not-- I thought, I can't
promulgate these things.
It's not a papal
thing from anyone.
Just, good luck.
Find who you love
and just, fuck them.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And dating?
I hate dating-- the word dating.
What does that mean?
First, you have sex, and then
you decide if you want to date.
Not the other way around.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Not
the other way around.
DANNY FIELDS: No, because if
you don't like the sex, then
how much more time are you
going to spend with this person?
OK.
All right.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: OK.
DANNY FIELDS: We're here
to talk about music.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yes.
Movies where they-- [LAUGHS].
So you still live in New York?
DANNY FIELDS: Yes,
I live in New York.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yeah, you
would never live anywhere else?
DANNY FIELDS: I would
gladly live anywhere else.
But I'm forced to live there.
And it's OK.
It's near-- there are airports.
And I spend a lot
of time in London.
I've been in London five
months this past year,
a month at a time.
And it's almost
my other city now.
It used to be Los Angeles.
And no one should be--
no one-- me should not
be limited to one place
because the world is so full.
And especially Europe.
Now, wait a minute.
Now, I'm in Europe.
But when I was in London,
I'm no longer in Europe.
That really sucks.
I can't believe that.
But I won't get into it.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Well, you're
definitely in Europe now.
DANNY FIELDS: I
can't believe what
it's done to my universe--
my London world.
Because it's just wonderful,
brilliant people--
artists and bar
owners and waitresses
and busboys and whatever.
I can't believe what
it's done to them.
This is like a shadow
over London this time.
Someone threw something on them.
There's this greatest,
wonderful city-- giant
city-- in the world and
they're all, what happens now?
This is kind of a tragedy.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: A lot of
people are very upset about it.
DANNY FIELDS: Too close to
it to even talk about it.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: So I
have one more question.
So if you have a
question in the audience,
you can start getting ready now.
So, 50 years in
the music industry.
Who-- if you look around
today-- you talked about all
of the artists and your
favorite artists earlier.
If you looked around
today, would there
be any artists
where you'd think,
god, I'd love to
have discovered them
or I'd love to be
promoting them?
DANNY FIELDS: Yeah.
There's always going
to be songwriters
and that's the most
important thing to me.
But I can't name one
and it wouldn't be fair.
I saw a band in London in an
almost empty bar in November
in Camden, called False Heads.
And I loved them.
I just loved their energy
and they were rock and roll
and we stayed friends.
What I can do for
them, I don't know.
I'm not in the
music business now.
Of the people I've worked with,
we said before, I'm-- Nico.
And now, I love--
everyone's going to hate me,
I love electronic dance music.
And I love-- well, this is
how it happened, if I may.
I go to a jam and
they play music.
And it's usually
late at night and I
work out and listen to music.
And there's this great song.
I said, wow, what is the song?
This is the number one hit.
I'm kind of good at that.
Not always, but kind of
good at spotting the hit.
And I had to find
out who's playing,
and it was a Spotify
fitness feed.
OK?
If you have a gym,
you can call Spotify
and say, send me fitness stuff--
music that we can put on.
And they can do bass
and drums or they
can do '80s, like Cyndi Lauper.
This was from the feed
called Tomorrowland.
This was my first encounter
with Tomorrowland,
which is a gigantic
and famous and-- how
could I not know what this was?
Because I'm not 17.
I didn't know what it was.
It's this franchise of new
electronic dance music.
And these giant spectacles,
where the lights-- I mean,
forget Van Gogh and
Rembrandt-- whoever
is doing those lights-- whoa!
This is an artist.
This is so great.
And then some guy's standing
on stage doing this.
Everyone's going crazy
and picking their arms
up in the air because they
know that you can't move
very far from side to side.
They know that.
They don't have to be
told and I love that.
And much of the music is great.
OK.
This one song was
by Stromae, who
is a Belgian-- half-Belgian,
half-- his father
was killed in the
Rwandan massacre.
How many people do you know
that you could say that about?
Now, I don't know
him but, well--
and his mother is Belgian.
And he's unbelievably great.
And he's got YouTubes.
And then his YouTubes will
take you to Tomorrowland,
where I saw Paul Kalkbrenner,
the Berlin genius.
And I always get a, duh.
And I get a jaw, like what?
And then last night, I
said, well, I like Avicii,
and there's this groan.
Oh, we want our money back.
Well, you know, well,
I like "Wake Me Up."
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: You
like what you like.
DANNY FIELDS: I mean,
what a great song.
It's the number one song.
That's all.
It's the song.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Absolutely.
OK.
I'm going to open it
up now for questions.
DANNY FIELDS: You hate
me because I said Avicii.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: No,
we don't hate you.
Does anybody have a question?
AUDIENCE: Hi,
Danny, how are you?
DANNY FIELDS: Can I use that?
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Yeah.
DANNY FIELDS: I
just want to see.
AUDIENCE: You want
to try this, as well?
This one, as well?
I was just wondering--
looking back
and one of my favorite
music ever, maybe,
is like Detroit,
MC5, The Stooges.
When that happened, it was,
like-- looking at the YouTube
videos, for example-- it was
the most energetic thing,
even by today's standards.
But then, after
that, became the--
DANNY FIELDS: What's
your question?
AUDIENCE: --the punk.
Is that--
DANNY FIELDS: I do this a lot.
Because I know you guys want
to contribute questions.
AUDIENCE: So what happened
to The Stooges and MC5
when punk happened?
DANNY FIELDS: Oh, god.
When punk happened?
Well, there was no punk
when they happened.
And they didn't happen.
And they were both fired
by the record company
that I signed them to.
Which, then, 60 years later,
said, well, we're so proud.
This is the record company that
brought you these two bands,
that they fired.
So the lineage is so complex.
I suggest you read,
"Please Kill Me"
for the American side of it.
And a book by John Robb
about punk in England.
The Ramones, in fact,
met each other--
because there had never
been four different kinds
of people-- because
they were Stooges fans
in their high school in 1970.
OK.
That's how they bonded.
It's kind of an answer
to your question--
is that you-- something
becomes something else
or comes into the mind and
consciousness of somebody else
who says, yes, we like
what they're doing.
Let's do it as they do.
The New York Dolls,
as well, which I wish
had been part of my life,
but they're not, formally.
Except I loved them
and they invented
another universe that went
this way and it went that way.
And then it got called punk.
I'm not sure by whom--
I'm not sure it works.
Someone said, oh,
the New York Times
is doing a big story on punk.
And the writer said, oh,
we'll get you an interview.
But in three to five sentences,
tell me what you think punk is.
I said, if I can't do it in
more than three to five words,
forget it.
And I haven't
picked them out yet.
But I would say young-- don't
get up there and flop around--
and stylish and
aggressive and fabulous.
So that's punk.
I don't know.
That wasn't an answer to your
question, was it, at all?
Come back.
Ask me a follow-up.
AUDIENCE: It was pretty much
an answer to my question,
all right.
DANNY FIELDS: You can have
a follow-up because that
was such a terrible answer.
I know it was.
AUDIENCE: Do you
know-- for example,
for MC5, it seems
like Wayne Kramer--
all that energy--
he's been doing,
now he's been to "Jail
Guitar Doors" thing, which
is interesting and important.
But I guess he just kind
of disappeared for a while.
DANNY FIELDS: Yes.
He's great and he's here.
And he's great.
And he was-- it was his
energy, the first time I ever
saw the MC5 on stage at the
Grande Ballroom in Detroit--
September 22, 1968.
And don't ask me
how I remember that.
But it was.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
That's impressive.
DANNY FIELDS: Great, great,
great source of nuclear fusion.
Something happening
there that is
extra musical, that's beyond
chords and notes and yes.
And Wayne is great.
And the band, unfortunately,
got a little bit meh.
Well, too political for a band.
And this did in the
Sex Pistols, as well,
who are another
great band who were
destroyed because no one
wants a band that's political.
It is not wanted.
It's associated with destruction
and revolt and smashing
and burning.
And it's unfortunate.
Next question.
No, I'm sorry.
We'll talk.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Actually, it's-- hi.
It's a follow-up on
what you just said.
So '60s, as we read
from books and you saw,
were also a time of
destruction and violence,
as well as a fight for
rights in the United States.
A lot of great
discoveries and trouble.
Much like what's going on
now in the United States.
Do you think--
DANNY FIELDS: I don't know
what you mean by that.
Because what's going on in the
United States cannot be said
in 20 words or less.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
DANNY FIELDS: And this is not
a Murdoch headline, so please--
AUDIENCE: Do you think
that this decade, with all
of the tumultuous
events, will bring us
something as culturally
powerful as '60s did?
DANNY FIELDS: Well, if I
could predict the future,
I'd be so rich and
famous, I would not
have to be sitting here now.
AUDIENCE: But you are.
[LAUGHTER]
DANNY FIELDS: I would
buy more than one island.
OK?
I don't know.
How can I know?
You guys-- it's up to you.
I'm getting off this bus.
It's up to you to steer
it from now on, I hope.
I'm sure there will be things
that we can't imagine now.
That's Shakespeare's-- "more
things in heaven and earth than
are in your philosophy."
There are.
And because there
are more of them,
it means we can't
give them a name
and put them in a
directory or a folder.
So I hope so and I believe so.
Or else there's-- go to Facebook
and talk about what you ate
for breakfast.
Or make the future.
I think it's a choice.
That's a bad answer, too.
It's hard to be simplistic
about these things,
but I know what
you want to know.
And I didn't make it.
I came upon it.
I came upon a mini
universe-- several of them--
that was generating excitement,
art, talent, wonderfulness,
songs, music, paintings, light.
All that.
Dance.
The future's going to be
putting them all together.
That's why I like the EDM shows
because it's all one thing.
I think that package is what
I'm really-- you will see.
I probably won't live to see.
But there will be that.
I know that.
Pass your plastic-- your sponge.
Oh, OK.
It's been passed.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering--
I've read that you
introduced Iggy Pop to Bowie.
And I was wondering if you
could tell us a little bit--
how'd that happen
or why did you--
DANNY FIELDS: OK.
I'll tell you how it happened.
Because-- this is
not miraculous.
There's no-- it sounds cosmic.
Oh, my god.
This meeting--
there must have been
one god touching-- you know,
the Michelangelo's ceiling
thing-- Adam's finger.
It did not happen that way.
David had come to-- David
had-- we knew he was--
we knew from reading
"Melody Maker"--
we didn't really know him then,
that he loved Iggy's work.
He loved Lou Reed.
And he came to New York and
hooked up with Lisa and Richard
Robinson who put
out "Rock Scene"
magazine and were widely
media-savvy in the '70s.
And Iggy happened to be
staying at my flat in New York.
And Lisa Robinson
called me and said,
we just had dinner
with Lou Reed.
And now David wants to
meet Iggy and I heard--
isn't he staying with you?
Yeah.
He's sleeping.
We'd just watched
some terrible Western
and he was sitting on the couch.
And [SNORES].
Come to Max's.
David wants to meet.
Can you bring Iggy
to Max's Kansas City,
which was the action
central hangout in New York.
It was just around the corner.
So, Iggy.
Uhhh.
I said, wake up.
David Bowie wants to meet you.
Uhhh.
The one who said you were
his favorite new vocalist
in "Melody Maker."
Oh, OK.
It's just at Max's.
It's around the corner.
Come on, wake up.
And so we walked the 200 or 300
yards there and it was late.
Almost-- there were
very few people there.
It was around 3:00 AM.
And I said, Iggy, here's what
you asked to be delivered.
And the two of them just
started talking about music.
And Lisa and Richard
and I, who were
responsible for this match,
went off in the corner
and ordered a port or vodka
and just watched them.
And yes, they seemed
to be getting along.
That was it.
So I didn't do-- it
was not miraculous.
It was, you're a house guest.
Get up, someone
wants to meet you.
That was it.
I had not plotted this.
Oh, some day, he
can-- because we
didn't know who
he was, except we
thought he was great and
fabulous and beautiful.
He was in New York
looking for his idols, who
were Lou and Iggy.
So that's all I did.
Just, Iggy, come on.
Let's go.
Let's walk a few blocks.
That's it.
And it becomes legendary
and you want to know,
what was really like?
It was really like
[INTENTIONALLY MUMBLES]
and they started talking
about music and we moved away
and that was it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DANNY FIELDS: Not--
there was not lighting
and the Red Sea didn't part.
Nothing.
Just, that was it.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
I think we have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Danny.
Thanks a million for coming.
It's really interesting
to hear you talk.
I understand you worked
with The Doors, as well.
I'd be curious to hear
how that relationship came
about and even what
you did with The Doors.
[DANNY SIGHS]
AUDIENCE: Or not.
Or talk about--
DANNY FIELDS: Well,
no, I mean, it's OK.
I mean, look.
They were part of
my life because-- it
was another accident.
A woman I knew in Los
Angeles said oh, my band
that I work with is
coming to New York.
Will you do this?
She was doing me a favor.
I had a band go
into Los Angeles,
she had a band come to New York.
Would you check them out?
See if there's anything
you could do for them?
They could use a little press.
I went to see them.
At about the same time,
my greatest groupy
gals-- I mean, the real
forefront of the-- that word
is patronizing, I know.
It's sexist, I know.
But these girls knew
what was happening.
And oh, he's the sexiest guy.
This great band playing uptown.
I heard it from them.
Then I get to the person
who represents herself
as the manager of the band.
Would you go see them and
see if you can help them?
So I went to see them.
And went, well,
this is a good band.
And I went to the rec-- and I
said-- I said I'm going, too.
I'm your press agent.
Hello.
Your LA woman asked
me to help you here.
OK, OK.
This is 1967, I think.
And I said, I'm going to come
and interview you and ask you
and each of you-- you sit there.
What's your favorite flower and
what do you look for in a girl?
And all that.
And that was the
beginning of that.
And I went to the
record company.
I said, hi, I'm your--
it was so different then.
It was like a little village.
OK.
And I'm the press agent for
your band called The Doors.
Oh, wow, we never
met a press agent.
They never met a press agent.
Come over.
And eventually, Elektra
hired me to just start
a press department for them.
And so I found
myself, officially,
the publicity person for
this person who turned out
to be an astonishing asshole.
Although, one of the
most talented people
I've ever known.
And one of the smartest.
And one of the meanest and
cruelest and most brilliant
and-- except for his poetry,
which is not very good.
Everything else
he did was, whoa.
He was extra human.
And you know he's
not really dead.
That's a whole other thing.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, there is a corpse
buried in Paris somewhere.
But he's-- he keeps making
trouble like he did then.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
I think that's it.
That's a great note to end on.
DANNY FIELDS: OK.
But I-- what can
I say about him?
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: Brilliant.
Listen, thanks so much
for being here today.
DANNY FIELDS: Thank you.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN: For
answering all of our questions.
DANNY FIELDS: Thank you.
FIONNUALA MEEHAN:
For sharing so much.
It was absolutely fascinating.
DANNY FIELDS: Thank
you and thank you.
Thank you.